katrina voici la liste des passagers on
a 200 personnes à bord a lu les bordés
on va bientôt décoller comment ça va oui
vous avez sauvé pas mal de vie en étant
piqué la façon dont vous avez posé cet
avion de tient du miracle
mettez du trim appliquer bêtement se
désagréger r30 millepied à leur tour ner
qu'elle commence à le retourner deux
parties
la journaliste a fait une vraie rock
star mais ce sera plus jamais à payer à
la seule sphère de tout telle commande
en vigueur voici hogan beaucoup besoin
d'un avocat
vous ne vous rappelez pas qu'on vous a
fait des analyses le soir du crash vous
aviez des traces d'alcool dans le sang
vous risquez la prison à vie le bureau
des enquêtes et auditionnent dans dix
jours les est sous le feu des
projecteurs maintenant sur quelque chose
la laine décembre ou est-ce que je peux
entrer je vous descendrait à l'intérieur
l'aviation civile a testé dix pilotes
sur simulateur dans les conditions de
l'accident et aucun de ses pilotes a pu
sauver un seul passager une était le
seul à pouvoir le faire
j'aimerais que vous me parliez des jours
qui ont précédé l'accident le sol est
normalement c'est trop lourd à porter
lui qui a précédé le vol j'ai pu goûter
coeur celle qui va se retrouver en
prison
mes clients ne vont pas en prison
[Musique]
7 vous sauver la vie on aurait pu poser
cet avion comme je lé fais
[Musique]